hey sweetheart look we're oh where'd she
go
okay there she is
she decided to come in the room and
visit while we were recording the show
yeah
she keeps oh do you have fleas it feels
good whatever it is look at that eye
oh yeah it literally scratch it scratch
it i know that feeling
that's like when you have a q-tip and
stick in your ear and it like feels
really really good
what you doing
oh
she loves her daddy no
yeah you gotta watch because she goes on
the back porch and
there's ticks out
we found a tick on her the other day
but we got it off the pookie
florida yeah
[ __ ] you're looking good
you look like you're a real [ __ ]
i've been drinking yeah you're looking
good she's going don't you like me don't
kiss me
you [ __ ] yeah she's like i'm going
i'm going over here did you see the
angry looks i know she's in the light
and she's like i'm gonna [ __ ] up your
camera
no see that's what sometimes when the
camera shakes that's what she's doing
yeah she's like why are you doing that
come here or biting it yeah which she
might in a minute yeah there she is
she's buying it that's the that's the
[ __ ] signature move
she bites everything she loves metal
things if it's metal she bites it yeah
look at her chewing it must feel good i
guess but it's like i don't i've been
trying to get her to stop doing that
like i got her all kind of chew sticks
and stuff but it works temporarily but
then she's like no i think i'm gonna
chew on this instead
oh my goodness bless you whatever it was
she was like that really sucked over
here
all right i'm gonna stop filming you now
okay you can go back
you can go back and lay down if you want
yeah
yeah
so yeah i'm gonna eat this [ __ ] i'm
gonna eat it i'm gonna eat it
you're so silly